NASA distr nounce it has discovered
organic materials the building blocks of
life all the way on Mars but that's not
the only fascinating space related news
to come out recently according to a
newly leaked Pentagon report in 2004 a
US aircraft carrier was stalked for
several days by a UFO that witnesses
said resembled a supersonic tic-tac the
object reportedly could hover in midair
and make itself invisible this shock to
confuse the Navy pilots who monitored it
Nick Pope was a journalist and
investigated UFO settings for the
British government he joins us tonight
Nick why would information like this I'm
not even seen this a million times but
why would we need to read about it
because it was leaked why wouldn't the
US government tell us this is there some
reason well I think there's always
embarrassment about anything in our
airspace that performance
characteristics exceed anything in our
own inventory and that by the way was
the conclusion in this Pentagon document
this thing ran rings around our f-18
Super Hornets that tried to chase this
thing
it was briefly tracked on radar but then
it seemed to be able to and this again
is a phrase from the document it's
almost like it cloaked itself and became
invisible you'd think this was science
fiction if you weren't reading it in
Pentagon documents and we know now which
we didn't know before that the
government took this very seriously and
these things are being seen in our skies
whatever they might be by pilots tracked
on on radar and there's a serious
defense and national security issue here
and dude just to be clear we don't
believe that any other country possesses
the technology that created an aircraft
like this right absolutely correct yes
one of the things that went into this
report was obviously looking to see if
this sort of thing was anything in our
own inventory and and indeed anything
that any other nation has I mean
certainly when I was investigating UFOs
for the British government we knew that
some of these things would turn out to
be secret prototype aircraft drones and
missiles but we always knew through our
own intelligence sources you know who
has what so you can eliminate
that so what you're really saying is
that the US government and the British
government have essentially concluded
that there are there's something not
from this world that humans did not
create that is being tracked on radar
and watched by people who watch aircraft
for a living I mean it's not this is
real it is real now the government
doesn't go so far as to say these things
are extraterrestrial but certainly when
I was doing this for the Ministry of
Defense our policy statement said
neither do we rule out that possibility
we said that we we kept an open mind on
this but of course you know these things
when their speeds and maneuvers are in
excess of anything that you've got or
anything that you're aware other nations
have you are forced almost to think the
unthinkable and and absolutely part of
the problem with this of course was just
that senior political figures and and
military chiefs often just said UFOs and
they rolled their eyes and and it was
the ridicule factor this seems like he
were able to say I'm sorry we're out of
time Nick but this just seems like a
story that we should be covering much
more than we do what I hope you will
come back thank you thank you I will do